the government celebrates securing a
three billion loan from the
international monetary fund but most Sri
Lankans are battling to make ends meet
foreign currency reserves fiscal
management debt sustainability mean
little to many people struggling to put
food on the table
unlike before it is very difficult and
we find it difficult to go on
things are so difficult now I really
think about the cost of living is really
got up I don't know what's going to
happen in the future given the money we
invest we can't get a proper return it
was different before but making a profit
is very difficult a series of bombings
in 2019 and the pandemic coupled with
economic mismanagement corruption and
unsustainable debt have pushed Sri Lanka
into its worst economic crisis since
Independence in 1948.
after months of negotiation the
government finally secured a four-year
loan from the international monetary
fund the first Trash will be made
available uh soon uh in in the next two
days or so
and going forward
disbursements will be tied to reviews
that take place every six months the
loan comes at a price with the
government forced to impose a major
austerity drive to secure it
this includes taxing more people and
introducing higher tax rates
the price of electricity and water have
risen and fuel costs almost three times
as much as it did two years ago
President Ronald Vikram singer addressed
the nation on Tuesday
approving the loan certifies that Sri
Lanka has the ability to restructure its
debts and will no longer be considered a
bankrupt country we can resume normal
transactions and remove import
restriction as our foreign currency
situation improves cracking down on
corruption and improving fiscal
management is a major part of the
program and Central to the reform the
IMF has insisted on there's an important
importance to improve the fiscal
institutions in particular public
financial management which is to improve
how the public management spend either
from tax revenues or financing from
vendors like us but some have questioned
how effective the program will be IMF
programs are often designed to treat the
symptoms of the problem and not the
cause and more than ever I think it is
clear to the IMF and everyone else that
Sri Lanka's fundamental problem is in
governance and in corruption
uh this program as it's been published
fails to engage that causal issues in
the country the IMF bailout will provide
much needed funds to allow Sri Lanka to
buy essential goods and help struggling
businesses but analysts say much still
needs to be done to allow Sri Lanka to
begin to recover Manuel Fernandez Al
Jazeera Colombo